buonasera
partiamo
da qualcosa di semplice e che quanto
sale prendete con il vostro pizzico non
sento non sapete quanto sale prendete
non sapete quanto sale mangiate questo è
stata la base un po per quando paio
d'anni fa il sottoscritto si è
interessato a questo alimento
fondamentale perché in cucina quando si
controlla il sale si controlla il gusto
si controlla la maggior parte del del
piacere gastronomico
però bisogna anche pensare vederlo sotto
un altro aspetto
l'eccesso di sodio noi in europa e in
italia
mangiamo quattro volte ingeriamo quattro
volte la quantità di sodio necessaria
per quello che è il nostro fabbisogno
alimentare e poi il sale e l'aceto sono
i due elementi per cui si litiga in casa
si litiga per stare nella pasta e
l'aceto dell'insalata se io riesco di
milan e uno diminuisco già del 50 per
cento i divorzi italiani questo è
partito un esperimento un lavoro uno
studio che è durato diversi anni dove la
parola come vedete dalle slide il caso
il caso in cucina per me non deve essere
non deve entrare in cucina in cucina
bisogna controllare le cose perché
altrimenti poi si dice mi è venuto male
invece l'ho fatto bene ho l'ho fatto ma
lo ripeto il punto focale poi anche ri
poter rifare le cose e quindi risalre e
sempre in modo uguale questo metodo
questo sistema attacca quello che la
regola quella classica dei dieci cento
mille 10 grammi di sale per 100 grammi
di pasta in un litro d'acqua che quella
che ha sempre funzionato
però bisognerebbe anche interrogarsi sì
ma per cuocere cosa per cuocere 1
spaghettino numero 3 che cuoce in cinque
minuti o per un pacchero che cuoce in 18
minuti perché altrimenti 15 grammi di
sale per uno saranno poco e per l'altro
saranno troppo in quanto con
l'evaporazione 18 minuti di cottura
questa le sarà totalmente concentrato
nell'acqua non c'è solo la pausa quindi
ci sono le paste quindi più cose da
dover vedere qui carrellata di minuti di
cottura quindi questo modo di pensare al
sale porta a un concetto che abbiamo
inserito un sistema di salatura né per
volume né per peso ma per tempo di
cottura e questo vi dà un'altra visione
il tutto porta che ci sono diversi tipi
di pasta diverse applicazioni e diverse
modi di salare in sala relax a o per la
pasta o per le verdure
arriviamo fino un punto molto
riassuntivo perché questo è quello che
poi lanciato i progetti quelli che di
cui vi devo raccontare che per meno
tempo di cottura
dobbiamo lasciare la base in acqua
maggiormente avremo sale e viceversa più
rimarrà nell'acqua e meno dovremmo
mettere il sale che cosa succede succede
che però alla fine tutto questo
riassunto all'interno di pasticche
pasticche di sale divisi
ecco questa è la cosa che dobbiamo
attaccare il qb quanto basta che non
sapete mai non sapete ma che cos'è
quanto basta allora questo via finito
non vide più cubi
arriviamo a queste tre pasticche che
hanno tre pesi diversi una servirà per i
cinque minuti di cottura una per i dieci
una per il 15 ma essendo divisibili
otteniamo se i pesi che sono sei numeri
che possono essere combinati e otteniamo
una scala che va da nove grammi 260
grammi anche per il pazzo che vuole
cuocere nella soluzione satura cosa
succede succede che però
scientificamente potete controllare il
sale se voi cuocete un etto di pasta in
dieci grammi d'acqua in un litro d'acqua
con 10 grammi di sale un altro con 12
grammi di sale e un altro con 8 grammi
di sale vi posso garantire che non
percepite in modo sostanziale a
differenza solo cotta e non dite mai più
bollita la passa bollita si fa bollire
l'acqua la pasta si cuoce come un
filetto già nobilitarla la passa allora
succede che percepite ma se mettete
anche soltanto realizzasse il pomodoro
vi posso garantire che vi sembrerà
uguale allora cosa vuol dire che abbiamo
tolto due grammi di sale
ad esempio in quella da 8 grammi in modo
e senti fico una famiglia che mette da
parte
2 grammi di sale per ogni porzione di
pasta arriva a fine anno che la mamma
capodanno possibile accendere i
mortaretti gira un secco da 30 chili di
sale sul tavolo che è quello che non ha
fatto mangiare la sua famiglia è qui
direi che dobbiamo cominciare a
ragionare quanto sia importante
controllare il sodio siamo arrivati al
sale ma il sale è soltanto uno dei gusti
primarie anche dopo che io ho lavorato
per due anni su sale
mi son chiesto ok perfetto adesso io
contro le sale poi faccio la mia pasta
all'olio con il parmigiano e la servo ai
due signori qua davanti uno iper
salutista che beve soltanto
spremute d'arancia l'altro che fuma due
pacchetti di sigarette al giorno con la
boccola palato asfaltato avranno una
percezione diversa quindi il non ancora
raggiunto niente anche mi sono
preoccupato
attraverso una scala o sei punti di
riferimento di arrivare a parare oa dare
dei punti dei punti di conoscenza per
quello che il nostro piacere
noi sappiamo perfettamente quanto
potenza abbiamo per alzare un secchiello
di sabbia o un'altra cosa ma il gusto la
nostra percezione del gusto non è non è
quantificabile allora attraverso un
piccolo kit con 6 punti 6 fiale tine
spray che uno si può usare sulla lingua
può determinare può determinare quello
che è il suo punto di piacere del gusto
dell'amaro dell'acido del dolce del
piccante del salato
a quel punto li abbiamo inventato le
taglie le misure del gusto se voi
entrate in un negozio di scarpe e
portato in 42 un signore non chiede 44
al 38 da misurare chiederà il 42
se io extra large vedevo chiederci un 58
inutile che vedo un modello 48
bellissimo 50 e chiedo di misurarlo so
perfettamente che non mi andrà bene
quindi stiamo facendo la stessa cosa col
gusto 6 punti cinque gusti primari un
piccolo più d'analisi decidiamo qual è
il nostro punto di sale nostro punto di
zucchero e questo vuol dire avere
un'identità del proprio gusto
l'identità mi ha portato poi veramente
all'ultimo salto che voglio presentare a
con onore all alt ed ex roma perché
l'identità e di chi sta bene del gusto
però dobbiamo iniziare a pensare
a chi ha delle patologie collegate a
all'alimentazione automaticamente dove
il cibo non è più qualcosa che è un
piacere è un qualcosa che normalmente
sembra una restrizione è un qualcosa che
sottrae e non dona non da non dà piacere
nel momento della tavola al momento
della commedia lita e quindi ci si
intende un po a isolarsi e quindi
abbiamo iniziato ad affrontare e per
fine anno ci sarà una piattaforma sulla
quale saremo molto operativi della dove
vorrò essere anche molto open source
poter dare consigli a tutti quanti
stanno combattendo una guerra personale
è che nel momento di cui arriva arancio
non sia freddo brutto e ghiacciato ma
che sia un momento per poter prender
forze e piacere per continuare la guerra
quel giorno e magari il giorno dopo
questo è un esempio semplicissimo uno
chef ala fine chiuderà sempre con delle
ricette libera sempre con del cibo è un
fritto per celiaci dove il celiaco
appena scopre se celiaco come in un
fumetto di si polverizza mentalmente il
piatto di spaghetti è il fritto se poi
pensiamo che bisogna andare avanti nella
quotidianità si rischia poi di far
mangiare tutta la famiglia non più in
modo allegro
guardate che la pasta per celiaci esiste
già soltanto dove la devi andare a
comprare e la confezione a quei colori
ni delle divise degli infermieri
dell'ospedale non c'è una confezione con
un pomodoro è una mozzarella che col suo
latte
quindi non ti dà allegria soltanto vede
la confezione
altro esempio è un agnello brodettato
guardate caso siamo a roma
si chiama maniello brodettato stop
running perché qui stiamo parlando e ii
b s
invece della della colite spastica e
questo ti aiuta a non correre perché è
ricco di triptofano quindi è un richiamo
alla serotonina e che aiuta
tranquillamente a rallentare le corse
però sono allegri soncini allegri uno
non penserebbe mai no che soffre di quel
problema di protagonita spastica
mangiarsi quel piatto lì che gli possa
far bene
io sto semplicemente cercando di
mettermi in mezzo a tutta la scienza
alimentare a tutto il sapere che c'è
specialmente negli stati uniti
l'altr'anno c'è stata una data storica
mi sembra che fosse 13 di novembre col
congresso nazionale degli allergologi
dove praticamente è stato sancito un
momento dove l'alimentazione diventa
qualcosa di fondamentale però poi ci
sono le materie prime ma che rimangono
tali e non possono poi diventare
appetibili se qualcuno non gli insegna
anche a casa specialmente a casa come
far godere magari un parente un amico un
compagno che sta soffrendo una una
patologia legata all'ambientazione
questo qui invece la bavarese di kiwi
giovani perché fa l'effetto contrario
che le meringhe sono fatte con la manita
è il manipolo e posso garantire che
potete anche offrire alla suocera o
all'amico che non vi è più tanto
simpatico equa chiediamo veramente con
la cosa più importante perché tutto
questo è successo quando la persona con
cui sviluppano questo progetto si chiama
matteo gol ed è un gastroenterologo
dell'ospedale delle molinette di torino
che viene al ristorante e vede che il
suo servendo delle cose micrometriche
quasi delle sculture gastronomiche sul
tavolo di fronte alla cucina c'era
seduto umberto che a questo mio amico
che sta affrontando il quarto cara il
cancro in quattro anni e il primo gli
hanno tolto lo stomaco
ma è una persona che ha sempre goduto
del cibo e si è trovato senza lo stomaco
allora matteo che il dottore vede 0
questi patti mi chiede come sto facendo
gli dico guarda sto servendo umberto che
praticamente non può mangiare a porzioni
micrometriche però questo non vuol dire
che non sia lo stesso alta cucina
io mi dice tu questo lo devi farlo di
divulgare e poi essere un qualcosa che
serve tantissimo a chi si trova in un
momento di disagio totale questa cui una
milanese con un purè di patate per chi
ha dei problemi di dislessia cioè quando
c'è cambia la percezione del gusto in
bocca
normalmente che sotto effetto
chemioterapico a in bocca un gusto di
ferro per una milanese se la si mette a
marinare al mattino per la sera dentro
un po di sciroppo d'acero con una
puntina di soia le voci di worcester e
dell'erba dolce delle erbe aromatiche
dolci come la maggior anno la salvia la
si lascia lì per 10 ore e poi la si
scola l'asse in panne a e con un pane
morbido non troppo non troppo secco
perché bisogna anche pensare che
normalmente ci sono i mucose irritate
magari può servire una milanese a chi
non ha più voglia di mangiare e
assolutamente non mangia la carne perché
gusto della carne ferroso ma forse
stiamo facendo qualcosa in quel momento
tutti quanti
io chiedo che ci siano questi chef
fighting che aiutino veramente chi è in
trincea tutti i giorni a portare avanti
la loro battaglia con un momento di
piacere
chiudo dicendo marchi chairless pharmacy